now everyone talks about plastic
pollution as a global crisis but what
exactly can we do to defeat it or
National Geographic and sky ocean
ventures have teamed up to launch the
ocean plastic Innovation Challenge and
this is a one-year competition which
will focus on strategic ways to reduce
single-use plastic in the ocean well
joining me now to tell us more about it
Group Director at sky's ocean venture
spread michelle and national Geographics
senior vice-president emma
Brasco good morning to you both and well
I was gonna say beautiful images behind
us but no they're not actually they'd be
more beautiful if we could see more blue
and less plastic and and and this is
exactly what you're trying to do as part
of this competition tell us what it is
it's a fantastic way to really
democratize solutions to reduce plastics
from entering our oceans three
categories that we're looking for one is
design so how can we prevent the actual
creation of single-use plastics think
about your daily cup of coffee or tea
that plastic lid there has to be a
different solution for it circular
economy how can we work with industry to
really look at their supply chain to
reduce plastics from entering the supply
chain and in the first place and the
last category is in the area of data
visualization so how can we better
communicate really complex potentially
overwhelming sets of data to help people
really understand for example what
happens when you put your plastic bottle
in the recycle bin
what's that journey like and so this is
a global challenge designed to really
invite people from all walks of life to
really put their best ideas forward and
join us in this effort to solve this
very menacing problem yeah this is
really an interesting idea because since
we launched the skies and rescue
campaigns sky's been working with big
companies to come up with solutions to
these big problems but what you're now
interested in is the individuals the
small start-up companies that could be
sitting on the big idea that helps this
I think we've done we've done a lot
around the awareness we've done a lot
around trying to mobilize players but
now the real specific ideas mi just said
come probably from across the world from
vulnerable communities were actually
affected by this this problem and we
want to hear from them when I hear from
them I move that's why this partnership
is the first very first time now sky
energy or get-together I think we share
very similar mission which is around
excellence and talents and trying to
reach the in talent so everyone is
invited to apply everyone is invited to
apply and also what we will be
developing is groans that will be put in
place and potential investment also
through our ocean ventures I support a
question for both of you is it given the
fact that you guys are essentially
incentivizing innovation why that
innovation isn't taking place already
national geographic person has been a
part of my life for years starting with
the magazine images like this I mean
pictures like this which we've all seen
haven't convinced people to start
innovating there's a million and a half
dollar a million and a half dollars
going to actually do so we we do think
so we're we're very bullish on
soliciting ideas really from people at
the front lines who were really living
with this issue each and every day and
so to be able to say to the world we are
open to your ideas we don't have them
all we certainly have a lot of them we
know that plastic pollution touches
everything that matters to National
Geographic our explorers are finding it
the deepest parts of the ocean to the
highest peaks of the world and it is a
problem it's a problem that is so big
that we need all possible solutions so
we think that incentivizing through
these three different challenges and
then looking to sky ocean ventures to
really invest and catalyze those
solutions and bring them to market is a
really really important step that's
interesting you mentioned bringing them
to markets afraid that's the next stage
of the problem isn't it you're getting
people to come forward with these ideas
so you know different materials that can
be used instead of plastic but it's
getting the big players the big
polluters to take those innovations on
board what are the main barriers that
you're coming up against when you Ames
these big companies look there are
alternatives
you just need to invest a bit of thought
into this yes for example one of the
areas we're looking at is the wrapping
of crisps for example this is extremely
expensive crisp packets can't be
recycled it's no it's it's very
expensive to really change the supply
chain in those products so what we're
trying to do is as you said sort of
create those ideas in the sky' machine
in a way help them grow and then get
them adopted and and the blocks I guess
is awareness probably but also
understanding that this is a progressive
stage mode already I mean those things
will take place over 5 to 10 years we
need first of all to find pragmatic
solutions that consumers can relate to
that's why those tracks those design
challenges were launching have very very
pragmatic you know the rappers the
containers the way people recycle and we
use if we come up with those parametric
ideas maybe the big players will want to
try them on their consumers as well so
that's why we're trying to encourage
consumer power does play a part here
doesn't it Emma because obviously
through Sky Ocean rescue we have so much
interaction with our viewers who are
horrified by what we show them about the
extent of plastic pollution and are
making small changes in their lives and
these small changes when added up do you
make a difference but it is the major
players you need to affect so consumers
and sky viewers player and National
Geographic viewers will play a huge part
in this every every single part of our
society plays a role so consumers
businesses government institutions we
all have a role to play when we when we
consider that 40% of plastic is used for
an average of 15 minutes but then can
live on for 450 years it's staggering
and so individual consumer changes
reduction of single-use plastics
elimination of plastic bags elimination
of cotton swabs those are all really
important steps that do lateral but we
need we need to catalyze really new
ideas that we believe are out in the in
them in the world okay and just quickly
is there a website that people can go to
you from your station yes indeed it's a
innovation that plastic - challenge org